i was a weird kid i grew up in the 90s i  was a bedwetter yeah  oh yeah i wet the bed every day i was 13  years old oh boy my mattress looked like  an old coffee filter yeah  [Applause]  oh man i ruined a lot of sleepovers  folks yeah  yeah you start to run out of excuses  after a while you know your friend's  like what happened here i was like huh  jeez i must have spilled a cup of piss  [Applause]  yeah  yeah they say a lot of bedwetters become  serial killers which i believe because  we learn how to clean up a stain pretty  quick okay  yeah  that's how embarrassing it is wetting  the bed i'll almost rather be known as a  murderer than a bed wetter you know  hey your friend sits on your mattress  why is it all crinkly i'm gonna kill ya  [Applause]